[Musique]
super méchants
cellules et costumes tristes
voulant que vous les pensiez tous sombres et
profonds à
quoi ressemble la
vie comme une punchline
[Musique]
mais tout ce que je prendrais
serait un acte béni de rébellion
pour que vous restaurez votre dignité  dans son
intégralité
[Musique]
vous savez que l'affaire complète la mission
vous obtenez 10 ans de réduction de votre peine
vous ne suivez en aucune façon mes ordres
et je fais exploser l'engin explosif à
la base de votre crâne
aimez-les ou détestez-le ce sont vos
frères  et soeurs pour les prochains
jours
des questions
et
oui c'est ta main très bonne
nous allons tous mourir
j'espère
donc oh pour l'amour de Dieu
c'est un suicide
eh bien c'est un peu notre truc
comme un bain de sang pour commencer le jour où
ils t'appellent pacificateur
je chéris la paix de tout mon cœur
je me fiche du nombre d'hommes femmes et d'
enfants que je dois tuer pour l'obtenir
toux sans
anse  sonne ta bouche harley non bien
que ce ne soit pas une invitation ouverte pour toi à
tousser sans te couvrir la bouche
toi